welcome to this video body go I never
played the sky azerbaijan hmm yeah maybe
let's do something no theoretical London
no I wanted to play III ah i know this
is come on can at least he took with the
poor not with an idea you would have
taken with the night I mean this is like
totally totally no compensation but if
he takes where the night I would have
been even worse yeah okay Wow okay this
is some sort of black majima gambit so
maybe i can i can get in some some sort
of spindle that's crazy efore what kind
of mouse slip is that long castles can I
get this in
it's not really great but after g4 I
won't Castle cut short yeah okay what
does he going for Queen III maybe maybe
that's actually interesting maybe I'm
threatening g4 h5 editore h4 h5 yeah h4
and then what exactly are you playing
Queen III and then I have a bishop txt
file how are you saving your bishop now
hmm funny check maybe I could have taken
on c2 493 check actually now I don't see
how it saves the bishop age 5 or is this
Queen a 3 anything like that I can play
f6 but then i take g6 this is definitely
definitely interesting amazing
check it's really just a pawn down for
nothing yeah this is a move that just
Rican c6 quite or not I is probably
quite frustrated yeah after this idiotic
a phone that actually got somewhat
playable game ID could have just taken
with the night only 44 suppose much
better
hmm
yeah to just double out on this one the
c6 bone I guess it's good let's queen a5
check check then rookie five
yeah rookie 7 trick I guess check I
can't go Queenie five now for the Queen
trade which is very simple I can give a
check here it's really just a check
going for Luke g7 and rookie seven okay
let's cover cover g-form
you have some extra time on the clock
that's good black resign yeah terribly
lucky gamer after this efore mouth
slipping I just wanted to play he three
and then I went here and you can just do
that after which is like well hmm no
compensation at all and here I mean at
least this is yeah I can pretend to have
some compensation here this black madam
ER kind of position somewhere around
here i'm already gambling with the
things here of course I mean maybe he
can really just take on f3 end and grab
the foyer I mean this is two pawns very
questionable affirm I have enough or
anything okay this is definitely also
also fine but here I'm not totally sure
him it's I'm already a little bit ahead
and develop second I thought maybe what
about this move is this possible I was
thinking that this could be an idea I ok
I can go here actually yeah ok I can go
here to recapture with the king I forgot
about that yeah ok so then this is not
an idea h5 however h5 yeah this would
have saved his bishop but that's
interesting already I can go look to f1
maybe trying to sacrifice him yeah i'm
just getting out of the age far this was
the idea at least i have some activity
but probably not enough yeah in the game
he just gave away his bishop and and was
like like totally lost him a very lucky
game efore was a really bad really bad
Mouse lib ok well thanks a lot for
watching